I'm Reem Alasadi. I'm a fashion designer born in Iraq.
I've made Britain my home and this is 'See Britain Through My Eyes.'
Portobello market,...
...the best place in the world.
I've been coming here for years...
...looking for things that we could probably remake, recycle.
When I hit a flea market, it's like a child in a sweetie shop.
My eyes pop open even bigger.
Can I pick up some things?
The clothes here tell a huge story about Britain.
Everything is a fabric of the nation, you know, liberty print, the little flowers.
These are obviously not Indian clothes,...
...but it's, she's adapted them and made them there and brought them back here.
And then right next door you've got Aquascutum and you can't get more English than Aquascutum.
It's this kind of multicultural society that we live in which is absolutely beautiful.
In Britain here, there are many symbols like,...
...you know, the face of the Queen on the coins, the Union Jacks,...
...all these things that you feel like you can own, you can play with...
...but you don't feel like anybody is going to put you in prison for them.